[Music]
i grew up in the 60s and as a young
adult heard a lot about people finding
themselves is it possible to actually
lose yourself amidst these stories right
now i'm 61 and i'm still not sure who i
am
yeah welcome to earth
first of all can you lose yourself sure
yourself can get buried under just
layers and layers of all kinds of stuff
in life right so for sure you can lose
yourself can you find yourself
i would argue that that's
a process humor well i would argue that
human beings are processes
essentially they're processes they're
constantly evolving constantly growing
you will not be the same person tomorrow
or even an hour from now that you are
right now
so you are a process you are in motion
so when people say i'm going to find
myself it's like really it's like well
the moment you find myself yourself it
will change
you know what i'm saying yeah so i think
it's the journey toward wholeness and
and toward a
an inner world that's characterized by
self-knowledge self-love
and and not in service to narcissistic
stuff but really in service to loving
others
to live in the world more beautifully in
service to
what uh we would hope the world could be
right
so
you know not knowing yourself is kind of
common i don't i wouldn't say i know
myself
i know i know uh
because i've spent a lot of work on it i
probably know myself better than people
who haven't done that work but
to think that you're ever going to
arrive there and go tada like and the
lights are going to go on is kind of
like a fool's errand you're right yeah i
totally agree because when i look at
something like the enneagram
it doesn't help me find myself as much
as
it like has a path towards finding
myself yes yes exactly and you know
we're all a little bit like the stock
market aren't we it's like it goes up
and down but you got to watch the trend
over time right yeah right yeah and so
if you watch your trend over time i
think that's what's important like am i
continuing to move toward
becoming the highest expression of who i
am or not yeah
yeah that's what i'd say when someone
says they're trying to find themselves
they've lost themselves quite often that
translates to
i feel incomplete in some way
and i think one of the reasons this
isn't the only reason but one of the
reasons we feel incomplete is because
the people and the organizations the
corporations the advertisers around us
have incompleted us yes they've told us
we're inadequate
by the way we're already good enough at
telling ourselves we're inadequate we
don't need the help of these
corporations although they create a
problem in order to sell you a solution
right and so
the only real solution is understanding
that you're already complete
there's already a complete human being
there
you don't need to do anything different
you don't need to become someone else
you can become someone else you likely
will become someone else but the needing
to become someone else is another
type of prison that we've created for
ourselves absolutely and so
i think
for this question in particular for
melody
and this can apply to anyone whether
they're in their 20s 30s 40s 50s 60s
we had a 92 year old show up at our san
diego event
a few years ago and she said i'm 92 and
i'm finally simplifying my life
and what i heard from that was
i'm finally finding myself i'm removing
the excess clutter now for her it was it
started with physical clutter but then
it was looking inside and realizing like
oh
i have all these broken stories that
have broken me as a person because i've
been telling myself that i'm this kind
of person and these things outside of me
will make me better will make me
improved will make me different will
make me whole and as soon as i accept
that as nonsense
then i can look inward and say oh maybe
i'm already complete so yeah i think
preparing broken stories begins with
realizing the emperor has no clothes
yes and calling it yeah right and then
saying
well who do i want to be
yes
right yeah what kind of story do i want
to inhabit yeah did you enjoy this video
if so you can listen to full episodes of
the minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel one
hundred percent advertisement free